hi everyone and thanks so much for
joining us
i'm maggie pockela senior manager of
global market development
in the genetic testing solutions
business unit here at thermo fisher
scientific
and today i'm joined by dr manoj gandhi
our senior medical director
i'm going to be having a conversation
with dr gandhi today about what we might
expect when covet 19
meets flu season and rsv season thank dr
gandhi for joining me
thanks for having me maggie it's a
pleasure to be here and having this
discussion with you about a rather
important topic
let's dive right in then so with sars
cov2 infections still spreading around
the globe
it's pretty apparent that we're going to
be at a point really soon where the flu
season
actually overlaps with the covet 19
pandemic
can you share a little bit about what we
already know about co-infections
of stars cov2 and other respiratory
illnesses
yeah first let's talk about kobe 19.
kobe 19 is quite a new virus and we as
humans
do not have any immunity to this novel
virus
as we have seen in the past six months
more and more of the population is
getting infected with the virus
if one has to learn from other viral
infections there is a very good
possibility that this virus could become
endemic
in comparison influenza has been around
for about 100 years
if you look at the early years of the
evolution of the influenza virus the
virus was also very lethal
while today influenza is still lethal
the mortality rate has dropped because
we as humans
required a level of immunity to this
virus and now
influenza is a seasonal virus and it is
only in the winter months that the
influenza causes
um sorry cases peak in the northern
hemisphere
the problem that we have here in this
situation is that this season the
influenza season
will occur while the world is dealing
with the kuvin19 pandemic
as far as co-infections are concerned
the question that you asked
it is more likely that the patient
either has one or the other
rather than having both infections at
once
there is limited data out there to say
if co-infections can or cannot occur
there is a very real possibility that
the patient who is infected with cova 19
can be infected at the same time with
influenza or vice versa
when one looks at the different studies
being conducted the most common
infections that happen within patients
with covalent 90 actually are patients
having infections with rsv which is
respiratory synthesial virus
influenza a influenza b and other
rhinoviruses
however the most likely situation that
would occur
that the patient would actually who the
patient who presents in the hospital has
either one or the other
and the odds of being co-infected are
rather small
another possibility is that the patient
gets infected
with one virus and recovers and then
after some time
all stick with another virus
and in the worst situation that a
covariate patient does get infected with
co-infected with influenza or rsv while
we don't know what the exact course of
the disease would look like
it is certainly expected to be worse
than if it were one
a disease at a time uh with rsv this is
something that is seen only in my young
children and
in older patients and again it is likely
that the patient has either one or the
other
or infections are possible but the
probability that you occur
is rather low that's all very
interesting thanks so much
so with all of that in mind what are
your thoughts on how
this knowledge and what you just shared
um and this twindemic
is going to impact patient management
so one of the issues that that we as a
medical community are concerned with the
flu season overlapping with this
pandemic is the patient
was the issue of patient overload and
the last year
hospitals used to gear up for the flu
season and when things would quieten
down after the season is over
things are back to normal however with
the pandemic
the health care systems especially the
emergency departments and the intensive
care units in some places that have been
really hard be hit hard by covert
are already being stretched to the limit
and now they have to deal with the flu
while no one really knows what the true
impact will be this is one of the
biggest concerns of the medical
community and that is patient overload
so that is one of the biggest concerns
that we will we will see as
as a society when the covet and the and
the flu season and the rsv season
will overlap okay
so how does one clinically distinguish
between the different respiratory
infections we're talking about
so covet and flu and rsv
and then what role does testing play
into that
the problem with these respiratory
pathogens is that they all present with
strikingly similar symptoms and these
symptoms are you know typically fever
cough body aches and runny nose there
are some subtle differences such as loss
of taste or smell
and shortness of breath and these are
seen generally in cobit patients
but this is not seen in all patients and
for the most part
the symptoms between covariate and flu
and even rsv are strikingly similar so
then the issue really becomes is how can
a physician really distinguish one
versus the other
now like i mentioned before rsv is
mainly seen as very young children and
older adults
and again interestingly covet is not
really known to affect children as much
we don't understand the reason why maybe
it is because of their immune repertoire
is not as well developed
as it does having said or having said
all this
it is really very difficult to
distinguish based on signs and symptoms
and one really needs to perform a test
to distinguish between them
okay perfect and so while we're on the
topic of tests
um let's talk a little bit about where
test makers fit in and of course that
also includes us here at thermo fisher
scientific
can you share any updates um about our
own portfolio for the upcoming flu
season
um yes uh it is really up to the
companies like thermofish scientific to
make the test that serve the needs of
the physician
and more importantly to solve the needs
of the patients
we already have a test that has received
emergency use authorization for the
detection of kovid19
however the flu season approaching what
we are doing here at thermofish or
scientific
is to make tests that can distinguish
covered versus flu
versus rsv in a single test so that with
a single test the physician is able to
distinguish between these diseases and
make the right decision for the patient
in the in this case of the provide flu
and the rsv test it is a pcr test that
is able to tell
whether the patient has covered versus
the flu versus er sweep
the test does not tell you specifically
whether it is flu a versus flu b
but it will certainly tell the patient
uh the physician in how to differentiate
between these three types of pathogens
really exciting to hear so while we're
on that differentiating ability
between these diseases with the tests
let's also bring in the therapies
so where do therapies fit in for flu
for rsv and even now for covet 19 as
we've made some progress there
you know one of the things that we have
seen is that you know whether it is
that whether it is kobe 19 or whether it
is flu or rsv the symptoms are fairly
similar like i mentioned before and and
the mainstay of treatment for these
diseases is mainly a symptomatic
treatment
so when we ask why does it really matter
you know if the symptoms are the same
if you distinguish one versus the other
and while it is true that
this that the treatment is mainly
symptomatic there are some subtle
differences and significant differences
in the treatment of co-weight patients
versus flu versus rsv
what we have learned in the acute phase
of kovid that there is a phase
where there is a cytokine storm and this
is where your immune system releases
these chemicals
that can actually have a very negative
effect on your lungs
and this is is what we've seen in when
it causes the shortness of breath that
we see in these patients
and we refer to them as acute
respiratory distress syndrome
this actually can be treated with
steroids and interleukin-6 inhibitors
such as tosalyzumab
in addition to giving these patients
respiratory support in in the form of a
ventilator
when you look at influenza we generally
do not see the cases where patients
actually have the cytokine storm
and therefore these patients really
don't present with the acute respiratory
distress syndrome
so there is no need to surprise their
immune system in fact
in influenza steroids are actually
contraindicated
because they actually are known to make
the disease worse by suppressing their
immune system
and making these patients more
susceptible to secondary bacterial
infections
similarly there are very specific
antiviral treatments that have been
approved for the treatment of coping 19
versus influenza
if you look at rem decibel that has been
approved for the treatment of co-weight
whereas it has not been approved
or not be tested in patients with
influenza
similarly antivirals such as
osceltamiver
or xana member have been approved for
the treatment of influenza
but have not been approved for treatment
of kobe 19.
when you look at rsv it is important to
differentiate covet or flu
versus rsv because if you look at
patients with rsv
while they present with the very similar
symptoms these patients really do not
need any specific type of treatment
and symptomatic management is sufficient
for this patient
also it is also very important to know
if the patient really has co-weight
versus the flu
or rsv because the prognosis is quite
different
flu patients generally have a better
prognosis similarly rsv patients have a
better prognosis
than in patients who are exposed to
covad19 and knowing this also is very
important
another important factor is the whole
issue of quarantining these patients
it is very important to quarantine
patients of kobe 19 to prevent the
spread or should we say slow the spread
or stop the spread
of kobe 19. with influenza or with rsv
we don't one may not need to follow such
strict quarantining procedures
similar to kobe 19. again with rsv
generally you see them in very young
children
and there is no need to quarantine uh
you know these young children and the
risk of transmission to the person
caring for the child
is quite negligible so for all these
reasons both from a patient perspective
as well as from a public health
perspective it is important to
distinguish covate versus flu and rsv
and it is only through testing can one
really distinguish if one has the covet
or has flu or as rsv
okay that's wonderful so there's also
been a lot of news
going around about a potential covid19
vaccine
and i know that that's still at least a
few months out but
there is a flu vaccine already available
to us so
what role is flu vaccination expected to
play in combating the so-called
twindemic that we're up against
um this is a great question um the flu
vaccine is certainly that is available
yearly and this year more than any
year once you certainly get the flu
vaccinated if it is available
i know in some parts of the world the
flu vaccine is not really easily
available and it's quite expensive but
in the united states here
flu vaccines are quite um generally
widely available and one should
certainly take it
as for whether the flu vaccinations will
help combat against the
against co-weight um it may play a role
in combating the twin damage by actually
fighting against the flu
what we know about flu vaccines is that
effective against the flu and even if
one gets
the flu after the vaccine vaccination
the symptoms are less severe than if one
did not take the vaccine
now coming to your question as to the
direct effect of the vaccination of flu
vaccination on covet
i don't think there is enough data to
show one way or the other the effect
that the co
the flu vaccination will have on cova
19.
the two viruses are quite different
influenza virus belongs to a different
family called the ortho mix of very day
family
whereas kobe 19 belongs to the
coronavirus family and these differences
between the structure of the two viruses
require that each of these viruses have
its own specific vaccine
we hope that there will be a vaccine
against cova 19 and at some point
it will become a part of the flu vaccine
in the future so that with one vaccine
there can be protection both against
covet
as far as the flu that's really
interesting
i've also read some some cool articles
about
acquired immunity um and i have to admit
i don't know much about it i was
wondering if you could explain a little
bit about what acquired immunity
is in the context of covid flu and rsv
uh this is an interesting topic and
really much remains to be known
the way i see it is squid is a very new
virus and we as humans have never been
exposed to this virus before
so like i said before there is no herd
immunity against coward 19.
with flu it has been around for 100
years and we as a species
have evolved with it and learn to live
with it with every passing year our body
gets used to a new strain of virus
either through natural infection or
through immunization
similarly like we have with flu or with
rsv
we have to learn to live with covet too
covet is just like
other viruses will also mutate and
whether it is through natural infection
or vaccinization when the vaccine
becomes available
our body will mount an immune response
our immune system would
a system would know how to deal with it
and as a result
as the virus evolves it would not be as
very virulent as it was when
we saw it for our body soil for the
first time this is the concept of
acquired immunity
however having said that we are very
early in the stage very early in the
process
and the journey our journey with kobet
has just begun
thanks for explaining that that was very
helpful um so we're kind of coming to
the end here and
my you know last question is just do you
have anything additional that you'd like
to share with us
about the implications of the sars kovi
ii reemergence during flu season
and any other complications that may um
may arise during the overlap
the one thing i would like to say is
that you know if we had to look at
one you know brighter you know spot in
kovaid you know through the whole thing
it's it's very hard to see the brighter
spots in this whole pandemic
is that there is generally more
awareness among people towards healthy
habits
um if people follow social distancing
practices very must
and ppe and also the greater emphasis on
vaccinations such as the flu
vaccinations
it may actually help decrease the
incidence of flu
this season and it may be milder than
previous years as a whole
in fact there are some preliminary data
that has come out of places from from
places like japan and taiwan
and in countries in the southern
hemisphere that just went through the
flu season and actually it was milder
than years before
so we hope that that is certainly a case
but only time will tell whether this
will actually happen so there's much to
be learned
uh as we come through this uh to this
endemic season
and and we'll see how things work out
yeah totally understand and thanks so
much i really appreciate
your time today dr gandhi i learned a
lot and i hope that our viewers did as
well
um thank you